Eh bien, je pense que oui
ils peuvent
[musique]
à cause de ce qu'il y a et de ce qui donnera en hiver, ils ont échangé
en été c'est certainement mieux car il y a moins
chauffer si nous ne donnons pas de chaleur signifie
la maternité va geler, alors on dira
Il y aura donc moins de nouveau-nés
il y aura un déclin
[musique]
il y a assez de défis en ce moment
J'ai également parlé avec les managers
non seulement c'est suffisant
le financement manque également
un grand nombre de personnel potentiel
des professions telles que les bagarreurs, qui sont extrêmement
important actuellement enrôlé dans les forces armées
L'Ukraine est protégée
patrie Mais néanmoins nous voyons
la charge sur la ville de Kiev est suffisante
grand
[musique]